they're leaving behind a life in Exile
crossing the border back into Syria
Lebanon is where hundreds of thousands
of syrians escape to during the war
there's mixed feelings and a lot of
uncertainty
some don't have homes nor jobs
but many say it's dire economic
conditions that are driving them back
I guess it is better to die there than
to die here the situation is difficult
here I can't even afford bread for my
children
it will be the same there at least there
we can find a place to be buried
the repatriation process is being
organized by the governments in Lebanon
and Syria
they insist this is voluntary
but rights groups say it lacks
transparency and have documented cases
of returnees facing abuse back home even
after receiving security clearance
they also point to policies by the
Lebanese government that makes life
difficult for refugees
between 80 to 90 percent of Syrian
refugees in Lebanon don't have legal
residency in the country which means
that they're subject to arrest and
deportation at the same time you have
politicians from across the political
Spectrum in Lebanon really amping up the
xenophobic and hateful rhetoric towards
refugees
Lebanon says it can no longer cope with
so many refugees and officials have gone
as far as to accuse the International
Community of not wanting syrians to
return to their country they believe
refusing to redirect Aid to Syria is a
way to put more political pressure on
Damascus
there are a very limited number of
political refugees we can't stop the
repatriation process because of them the
unhcr should settle them in a third
country
the U.N Refugee agency says it is not
facilitating the return of refugees at
this stage as Syria is still not safe
for them it seems many syrians feel the
same since 2016 the UN has verified
nearly 80 000 have returned and less
than three thousand have signed up for
repatriation in recent weeks that's a
small number
those who don't return are from former
strongholds of the opposition in Syria
and could face persecution in
pro-government areas and many now live
in fear as Lebanese authorities say this
voluntary repatriation process is only
beginning
arcel Northern Lebanon